♪♪
Emily:
Here's an idea.
Let's just run all the way to
the edge of the earth and...
fall off.
♪♪
Sounds nice.
♪When the night is long♪
Emily:
Promise me something, Sue.
♪♪
That you'll always love me more
then him.
I wouldn't worry too much about
that one.
♪Cause all I want is you♪
♪All I want is you♪
What are they so afraid of?
Maybe they're scared if they
teach us how the world works
we'll figure out how to take
over.
Hmm.
You really are my favorite
person in the world.
♪♪
You know I'm gonna miss sleeping
in your bed, right?
♪I'll shelter there with you♪
You're the only one I have.
Without you... I might as
well not exist.
Sue:
I have to tell you...
I never though I'd be jealous
of... a man stealing your heart.
♪♪
You jealous?
Sue:
Marriage and motherhood, it's
too much.
It's all too much I...
I... I hate the fact that...
That what?
...you are not doing it with me.
♪♪
Only you would show up at a
party... looking like a raccoon.
I'm not here for the party.
I'm here to see you.
Emily: I need to know.
-Sue: Emily!
What did you think of my poems,
tell me?
I loved them.
The biggest thing that I don't
want to feel..
Is what?
Emily:
Hmm.
Is what!
What is it, Sue?
Just say it!
Is that I'm in love with you.
I don't believe you.
It's true.
What is it that you crave?
You crave meaning.
You crave beauty.
You crave love.
I love Sue!
And I, I want her and I can't
get enough of her.
And if I was on my deathbed
right now all I'd want is, Sue!
♪All I want is you♪
♪When you're drowning in the
blue♪
♪I'll shelter there with you♪
♪Do what only I can do♪
♪♪
Emily:
I can't live with you.
I can't breath without you and I
can't write without you.
♪♪
♪All I want it you♪